[Music]
have you ever noticed something swimming
in your field of vision it may look like
a tiny worm or a transparent blob
and whenever you try to get a closer
look it disappears only to reappear as
soon as you shift your glance but don't
go rinsing out your eyes what you are
seeing is a common phenomenon known as a
floater the scientific name for these
objects is mu sky Valley tantas Latin
for flying flies and true to their name
they can be somewhat annoying but
they're not actually bugs or any kind of
external objects at all rather they
exist inside your eyeball floaters may
seem to be alive since they move and
change shape but they are not alive
floaters are tiny objects that cast
shadows on the retina the
light-sensitive tissue at the back of
your eye they might be bits of tissue
red blood cells or clumps of protein and
because they're suspended within the
vitreous humour the gel like liquid that
fills the inside of your eye floaters
drift along with your eye movements and
seem to bounce a little when your eye
stops floaters maybe only barely
distinguishable most of the time they
become more visible the closer they are
to their retina just as holding your
hand closer to a table with an overhead
light will result in a more sharply
defined shadow and floaters are
particularly noticeable when you are
looking at a uniform bright surface like
a blank computer screen snow or a clear
sky where the consistency of the
background makes them easier to
distinguish the brighter the light is
the more your pupil contracts this has
an effect similar to replacing a large
diffuse light fixture with a single
overhead light bulb which also makes the
shadow appear clearer
there is another visual phenomenon that
looks similar to floaters but is in fact
unrelated if you've seen tiny dots of
light darting about when looking at a
bright blue sky you've experienced what
is known as the blue field entoptic
phenomenon in some ways this is the
opposite of seeing floaters here you are
not seeing shadows but little moving
windows letting light through to your
retina the windows are actually caused
by white blood cells moving through the
capillaries along your retina surface
these leukocytes can be so large that
they nearly fill a capillary causing a
plasma space to open up in front of them
because the space and the white blood
cells are both more transparent to blue
light than the red blood cells normally
present in capillaries we see a moving
dot of light wherever this happens
following the paths of your capillaries
and moving in time with your pulse under
ideal viewing conditions you might even
see what looks like a dark tail
following the dot this is the red blood
cells that have bunched up behind the
leukocyte some science museums have an
exhibit which consists of a screen of
blue light allowing you to see these
blue sky sprites much more clearly than
you normally would while everybody's
eyes experience these sort of effects
the number and type vary greatly in the
case of floaters they often go unnoticed
as our brain learns to ignore them
however abnormally numerous or large
floaters that interfere with vision may
be a sign of a more serious condition
requiring immediate medical treatment
but the majority of the time in top tick
phenomena such as floaters and blue sky
sprites are just a gentle reminder that
what we think we see depends just as
much on our biology and minds as it does
on the external world
you
[Music]